hey my name is Ben Schwartz I'm here at
BuzzFeed to talk about my new film Blue
Iguana with Sam Rockwell coming
everywhere August 24th and it my friends
is time to s some tea
which means spill some tea shall we
watch as I do it hold
whenever you pour tea gently cradle I
felt this the armpit and as high as you
can go and as slow as you can come join
me I feel like when we look back at the
show the writing staff of that show is
so strong if you look at it it's like
the best writers and so when we got
scripts it was always the funniest thing
I'd ever read so we would always do it
as is and I'll play a little bit and
then many times we'll do something
called a fun run at the end where you
can kind of go nuts we got what we need
to go nuts sometimes they keep some of
that sometimes you know but the words
were always great that show the writers
on that show it's a very special special
thing there's a really special show Jon
Ralphie and I have many traits in common
we have the same hair any time I play
Domino's yo I would grow up my hair as
long as I could so when it came time I
looked as stupid as I like me and the
hair making people I had like the best
time making me look like a crazy cartoon
character every time we did it I would
probably want to switch with Pratt Pratt
or perd hapley
and I could never do Nick Nick
Offerman's cat he's just too perfect
like I can't I wouldn't be able to do it
yeah I think I'd probably say Pratt or
perd hapley perd hapley is one of my
favorite characters on all television
I think he's so funny I think he's so
funny I think most of my scenes were the
Z's and he's incredibly funny Jenny
really made me laugh Jenny's so funny
Jenny really made me laugh Pratt crap
makes me laugh
I don't know about cracking up on the
spot but anytime anybody improvised I
would go it would make me so happy but
often times when I'm gonna scene I'm the
crazy person the other person is a
straight man because my character is so
insane everybody there I'm talking about
like Rhetta Jim everybody there amy is
obviously an icon a legend they're all
incredibly funny I don't remember I'm
sure all that made me laugh at some time
because they're just in May they're
amazing they're truly amazing I love
those guys so much can I say something
about tea I do love tea and one of the
reasons why I love it is that it's
delicious
it's classy I mean it's really hard to
know how much I enjoy it until I really
pour myself a good cuppa
a good cup of tea yeah one of my
favorite John Ralph field lines is we're
exiting a car we're exiting in a van it
was after that after that episode where
Nick is dancing like this with a tiny
hat or everybody drinking snake juice
it's very small line we're leaving and
I'm in the back and as the car pulls
away everybody's laughing and as they
pull away I go I'm so alone that's it
it's such a small line and I can't
believe it made the cut I mean Don
Cheadle to me listen to be that good
he's such a good actor she does
incredible you know today's Kristen Bell
like treated us like she was so
incredible and then took care of us and
then while she was doing that she had
two kids so like she was able to do
everything and manage everything and
then take care of us as well which is
incredible and chill man you just it's
like every day is like class you can
just sit back and watch one of the
greatest actors of all time do what he
does and also you gain confidence
because when you're in scenes with them
but you create with him and you create
something together and so it's very it's
very exciting to be around both of those
people for those reasons do my drink
right can you guys be honest I drink tea
weird because I'll do this in a
restaurant
I don't like to I just like to get on
the very ends of it I don't know what do
people say about me Oh what's happening
sometimes people would think that I'm
very much like John Ralph Hill because I
played him or that I'm a little bit of a
douchebag because I feel but I'm I'm
very much not like that I actually don't
really get to go to clubs or anything
like that usually oh yeah this is a mess
there's a mess what a mistake and I stay
in my clothes and I got more press today
I can venema you for the rug I think if
you don't want to switch characters
anybody for a day what would it be it is
easy it would probably be either Sonic
the Hedgehog or do we duck first of all
if I'm Sonic I can run as fast as
anybody and I'm also my hedgehog and I
guess I love
so I'm very into that it probably would
be Sonic how cool would that be I can
turn into a ball I think what are you
crazy
I love that the process of me getting
Sonic was a long one a really long one
it started a year ago what was I I think
the director Jeff called me and he said
that you know it's the role is yours I
did like a tiger woods' one of these I
was like fist pumped and then looked
around cause out in the open that one
was oh I put in a lot of work to get
that one I really wanted it so I was
very very excited hey my name is Ben
Schwartz and I'm still at BuzzFeed this
has been so much fun listen we spilled
some tea literally check me out with Sam
Rockwell movie called Blue Iguana August
24th it is gonna be on s VOD which I
think means everywhere that you can
download things on demand I'm assuming
and then it's gonna be in theaters as
well same time and Sam Rockwell just won
an Oscar so I mean like there's way more
pressure for him than me enjoy the movie
this is the most serious interview I've
done no joke you can ask them every
other interview has been me going crazy
and it's a BuzzFeed which seems like the
place that you drove the most crazy
[Music]